Here is the outline of the dart throwing program. We need to complete the part
here where X and Y should be random numbers between minus one and one. So we
can't just call generator next double, cause that gets a value between zero and
and one, and we want a value from minus one to one. So here's the trick, take
the value from zero to one, multiply by two. That gives you a value from zero
to two, and then you subtract one, which shifts it to the left by one. Here is
the final expression. And of course the very same expression will work for y.
Now we need to find whether the point lies in the unit circle. He can compute
the distance just like you've done in the telescope problem, but it's actually
a little easy in this case. I can take the square of the distance, and check
whether that's less equal one, because the square root of one is just one.
Don't worry about it if you're just used to formula. It's not a math class, so
any correct formula will do. Let's run the program. And once the number of
tries, we'll try a million and we get a pretty respectable estimate for pi. And
like a said there are better ways of computing pi, but this method of using
random numbers for measuring objects is really powerful when the object is
irregular. When it's easy to find out whether a point lies in it, but when it's
hard to compute the area with traditional means.